il se surnomme ryder et d'y boire pour
soulager son mal de vivre par luis au
poids mais pas mal pour lui et bien
d'autres sans abri
il est impensable de dormir dans un
refuge où on interdit la consommation
d'alcool non par laquelle des gens qui
boivent de l'alcool tous les arts
donc pour eux passés de 12 bouteilles de
bière en une heure à 0 pendant 4 5
heures c'est impossible
physiquement elle tombe malade et pour
contrer ce problème un premier refus
j'avais consommation d'alcool voit le
jour au québec dès janvier on
accueillera dans l'ancien hôpital royal
victoria une quinzaine d'itinérants
alcoolique au rand paul est en vue j'en
veux une horde puis en vue une autre
puis qui décide comme ça il ya vraiment
un plan de consommation si on veut
qu'ils étaient habiles avec l'équipe du
liban où pour chaque sans abri un niveau
de consommation sera établi avec une
équipe de professionnels et
contrairement au refuge conventionnel
chacun aura une chambre privée
au lieu de passer la nuit dans un
dortoir qu'un qu'ils acceptent de faire
le programme peuvent rester 24 septembre
si longtemps qu'il le souhaite réduire
la consommation de ses alcoolique pour
les aider à briser le cercle vicieux de
l'itinérance
on vit vraiment habilité au niveau de la
consommation qui permettrait d'être plus
fonctionnel que ce soit l'accès au
logement que ça soit de faire des
démarches pour avoir de l'aide sociale
pour avoir ses papiers sarac eu son
certificat de naissance des choses qui
sont plus difficiles à faire quand on
est à la rue l'expérience sera analysée
d'autres refuges avec consommation
d'alcool pourrait être créé ça peut être
un programme un appartement ça peut être
un programme en refuge un programme
ensemble deux jours ici doivent être
utiles et radio canada
mon frère